the question for you going through
having been say I love you to you and to
Lauren yeah are you gonna be super aware
of that with the guys that was the worst
feeling there was so much validation
coming from him that I think that's
where I got confused and I think for me
learning from that if I start to feel
those feelings I think I'll be very
cautious about who I say that - because
I know what that felt like for me and to
say I love you and not be a hundred
percent about it I don't think I would
do it did I feel like ready to get
engaged I really do it you know I when I
was with Ben I was mentally totally
ready to be engaged and be done with
dating and just start my life with him
and I was so excited about that so when
it ended I mean I was crushed I was
devastated but it reminded me that that
was something that I really wanted and I
mean I see you guys and Tanner and
Jade's wedding and I see that and you
know I get like teary-eyed watching
because I'm that's what I want and it
just I'm really excited and I hope that
I find somebody I'm scared that I may
not but it's definitely what I want